since Jeff Bezos unveiled plans for
delivery drones a decade ago progress
has been slow today there are only a few
thousand delivery robots currently
operating in the U.S but that's about to
change in December Prime error
successfully completed commercial
deliveries in College Station Texas and
Lockeford California on the other side
of the world maituan and Alibaba have
just started rolling out the service to
their customers as well in the U.S
delivery drones have been hindered by
the FAA approval process and it's the
same story in China but I predict that
won't be true much longer in terms of
the overwhelming benefits the service
brings convenience for customers and in
reducing the traffic problems caused by
delivery trucks clogging up our streets
by 2050 I'm confident that the urban
Skyline will be buzzing with what will
look like a swarm of carrier pigeons
bearing books spatulas bottles of
vinegar or whatever else you might order
on Amazon not to mention hearts and
kidneys racing towards hospitals